winter is coming and some punches get
thrown sons of the harpy I gotta be
honest I'm a little bit annoyed with
this episode because on the one hand I
said before that I needed some things to
start happening and some things do
happen in as far as we get a couple of
action scenes a couple of good ones and
some characters that I like get chances
to be pretty badass I still don't feel
like anything major really happened I
mean then it was more active and that
was nice but it felt like superficial
action it was there to punch it up and
make it more exciting but it didn't
actually mean a heck of a lot I mean not
to say that this episode is meaningless
but I do feel that fundamentally at its
core it's still just very slowly getting
to stuff that actually will have more
impact but what do we have going on we
have surged auras known in some circles
as Sir friendzone comes on back for the
first time since Khaleesi kicked him out
and I'm a lot of a torn on his
reappearance I'm glad he's back I like
him as a character but there's a there's
a certain disconnect between what at
least I understand it is that he wants
to have happen and what his actions
actually are because I don't see the
inherent connection between what he's
doing and what he thinks it's going to
accomplish we get a bit more going on
with the sparrows in King's Landing and
I'm still loving the high Sparrow I
really like the feel of him and just the
sincerity of the character I really do
enjoyed that said I feel like and this
is gonna sound like an odd complaint
giving that I just said about things
moving too slowly I feel like the
sparrows have sort of gotten where I
figured they were going a little too
quickly in that I'd compare sort of what
that group was the last episode of where
they've suddenly jumped to this episode
I feel like I missed a middle step
somewhere over a marine we get a bit
more with donairs but really in marine
we're dealing much more with the titular
sons of the harpy which is kind of the
little internal uprising that I talked
about before and while it's not
uninteresting I'm not in love with it
largely because it results in the feel
of what's going to marine being very
similar to the feel of what's going
on in King's Landing and I don't like in
a story this big with this Mesa realize
that two of the major ones are feeling
very similar over in Dorne we get our
introduction to the sand snakes which
are the offspring of Oberyn Martell and
they have a cool little interesting they
don't do much they're really just only
introduced and I'm hoping that they will
inject a little life or at least start
throwing other people's plans out of
whack which seems to be the vibe I'm
getting off of them we have brawn and
Jamie now I whatever reason I felt like
saying that Braun was paired off with
Jaime Lannister you know sort of as a
duo was some kind of spoiler it's not
really just saying that that they're
working via and they got paired off
there are really good pairing and Braun
has a rapport with jamin not dissimilar
to what he had with Tyrion now obviously
Jamie and Terry are different characters
but brawn is still bringing that same
brash up front honest rogue routine that
I always loved and he it works with
Jamie as well as it did Batarian so they
have some really good stuff I think I
without a doubt the best scene in this
episode for me is actually between
Stannis and his daughter and it's not a
scene that really has much to do with
anything is kind of superfluous and I'm
surprised it's in there but I love that
it is because it's just a really
wonderful scene and it shows us aside to
stand us that we haven't seen before and
it deepened him as a character and it
just gave me more reason to like his
daughter who I kind of liked anyway
maybe if for no other reason then I hate
his wife and his wife doesn't like the
daughter so that kind of put me on her
side right off the bat but it's a really
nice scene and I think it was probably
the highlight of the episode for me I
don't really have much more to say about
this episode like I said it there's more
going on in terms of kind of whiz-bang
Oh flashing exciting yay but I look at
the substance of and I feel like we're
not getting things moving forward any
faster than we were the last few
episodes and it's starting to wear on me
a little bit i'm getting that same kind
of fatigue i got in season three but i
am starting to get a little bit
frustrated with a show at this point i'm
not gonna say mad cuz i can still sort
of see on the horizon all this stuff
that that's gonna happen
start impacting these but am i doing
you've got so many storylines can just
one of them start really steaming ahead
with it with a bit more force just just
one so i guess i'll ask this of the
various storylines that we've got going
on in terms of Jamie and brawn Tyrion
and Varys surge auras nua gender Stannis
arya Sansa who actually has some nice
moments in this episode as well of all
these storylines that are going on right
now what is the one that you are most
interested to see the next step and
whatever one it is drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
until next time this council is a jerk